- So, you play poker professionally.
That is so cool.
- [Jennifer] I love poker so much, and-
- [Kelly] Look at that!
Look at those eyes!
- Here I am, look at me.
Oh, yes, I am very,
and I have a rock crystal
ring on my finger, yes.
- [Kelly] Okay, okay.
- I feel like part of playing poker
is looking fabulous while you do so.
I think I'm the only one,
my boyfriend's a
professional poker player,
and he wears like a hoodie and sunglasses
and he likes to look really weird,
but I like to look
glamorous because you know,
that's what I've got,
that's what I've got.
- So wait but in poker you
have to be able to bluff,
and I feel like you have like
- [Jennifer] Yes
- More energy than me.
So how do you do that?
- Well, I think the thing
when I first started out,
cause actors are,
you've trained yourself to
have a very expressive face.
So if you're sitting next to somebody
and you're saying "I love you",
but you actually can't stand them.
You let a little bit
of that inner revulsion
flicker across your face.
- Revulsion.
(laughs)
So if you're in poker and you're like,
"I have a really great hand"
and then you're like, gulp,
then, you know that sort of like your-
- You get your tell.
So I had to let, not all
my emotions flicker off my,
across my face.
Just the one that I wanted to flicker.
And it took me a couple years
to train myself out of that.
But I'm also really good
at bluffing because,
- Wait did you just say
you're now a trained liar?
Is that what we're doing?
(laughs)
- Yes, yes.
Look out Phil, my boyfriend.
Yeah, I was out with the girls last night.
- Oh my God!
- She was!
(laughs)
- [Jennifer] No, I'm
always out with the girls.
That's what I do.
Drinking Cosmopolitans
just like on my Sex and the City.
- So wait, let's do a little experiment.
- Oh, I love experiments.
- Let's see if Jennifer can tell,
- As long as it's not scientific
- And who's lying and who's not
- Like operation experiment.
- No no, you can't see it,
- Oh no, okay.
- You can't see it.
- Oh this is so fun.
- Okay, so we're gonna
call this experiment,
Looking for a liar.
♪ Lookin' for a liar ♪
(audience cheering)
I love you.
Okay.
Jeremy and I each have a card
and on these cards are
stories from our lives.
We will read the stories,
Jennifer will get to ask a few questions
- Right
- Then she will have to determine
- Okay.
- If each of us is either
lying or telling the truth.
- (whispering) Looking for liars,
looking for liars.
- Are you ready?
Okay, are you ready? You can
go Jeremy, you can go first.
- Lets go Jeremy, I'm gonna
watch you like a hawk.
- Okay, watch me.
(laughs)
Okay.
My first big gig as a
Modesto Junior College,
and this guy comes in and says,
Hey, you want to make 50 bucks?
and I said yeah, yeah.
You train the police academy guys, right?
So the real cops would come in the room
and he put me in this closet,
they just said, be unruly
and don't let them,
you know, arrest you
- Right.
- And so I kicked them in the (beep)
and they paid me 50 bucks.
- [Kelly] What?
(audience laughing)
- And that was my first job.
- I think that's a lie.
I'm just guessing it's a
lie because you didn't say
I kicked them in the (beep)
like with the delight that you would have
if you actually kicked
somebody in the (beep)
(laughs)
I mean you were looking at it like,
I've never seen this before in my life.
How did they come up
with something like that?
- Or is he acting, he's
just trying to throw you.
- I don't know cause I think
Jeremy is a better actor
than that.
- [Kelly] Wait, is it true?
- It is true, yeah.
- It is true!
(audience cheers)
I knew you were acting!
- But, okay, it is true,
you were an unruly person.
- I thought you were acting
- I knew it when you put that
jacket on, you're a rebel.
I was like,
oh, nice clean cop boy, would never
kick a police officer's (beep)
and get $50 for it.
Okay, wrong.
- I can't believe you
kicked a cop in the (beep)
- That was rude, did you
have steel toe boots on?
- No, it was actually just,
it was actually a really cool thing,
but they do have to like train the-
- [Kelly] What?
- [Jennifer] Not for him.
- Not that I kicked the guy in the (beep)
but you know, I did my part.
- Yeah, that was a little
overly enthusiastic.
Don't you think?
(audience laughing)
- Yes, I know it was.
- But, you were telling the truth, okay.
- Okay, if you we're telling the truth,
then I'm gonna say you're telling a lie
cause you can't both be telling the truth.
- Okay, I don't know.
- Its like we're shamba.
- I don't know,
so this is my story.
- Okay, I'm guessing it's a
lie even before she says so.
Help me, help me!
I'm not good at this, I want
you to tell me what you think.
- Okay, this is my story
- Okay.
- Okay, so
literally right after I
graduated high school,
- That's a lie.
(audience laughs)
- I did graduate.
- You didn't graduate.
(laughs)
- Barely.
No, right after I graduated high school,
I moved to LA with this
girl I didn't know.
And we ended up being roommates
and she asked me to go
out with her one night
and I was like, I had a
lot of jobs I was like,
well, whatever, I'll do it.
And I never went out in LA.
And so I went out and I'm
dancing on the dance floor
and all of a sudden this
person is behind me and like
getting really like on me.
And I'm like, oh, I didn't
come here to see you dude.
And so anyways,
so I turn around and the man
grinding off on the side of me
- [Jennifer] Hugh Hefner!
- Hugh Hefner.
And then I did the slow Homer Simpson GIF
and backed into the bush,
like all the dance floor
because I do have daddy issues.
But not that neat.
- Yeah, okay.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I'm gonna say that is an untrue story
because your story was true.
Kelly, you're too wholesome of a girl
to be grinding with Hugh Hefner
(laughs)
- I wasn't grinding with Hugh Hefner,
I turned around and he was there.
That's a real story.
Here's why it's unbelievable.
Because one, all my
friends would have guessed
it was unbelievable too
cause I don't go out.
And then two, it did happen
and I was dragged out.
And then the one time I was dragged out,
that happened and I was like, (whining)
this is why I don't go out.
(everybody whining)
It was really funny though.
They were actually very nice
and funny on the dance floor.
I just, you know, backed out.
Cause I was like.
- Everybody is funny and
nice on the dance floor.
Wait till they get you in the dark alley.
(laughs)
- What!
- I worry about her.
- I don't want to be in a dark alley!
With anyone
(laughs)
- Not even Jeremy
- I gotta see this Chucky thing.